Hi everyone, my name is Mike. I'm from the Burp Suite desktop development team and today I'm here
to talk to you about the new tool we've recently added to Burp Suite called Organizer. So we've
been speaking to users and one of the recent pain points we identified was that people were having
trouble collating interesting requests and responses that they found while pen testing
and evaluating web applications. Let me jump into Burp Suite and I can show you what I mean.
So that's a good well-timed automatic backup. So here I am on the dashboard. If I move over to the
Repeater tab you can see that I've tried to collate all the interesting requests with their responses
in Repeater using Repeater tabs. Now this is okay, it works kind of well, but the issue is that we're
not able to filter, search or sort these results and we're not able to accompany it with any free
text data. So if I find anything out at the time I'm not able to store that alongside the request
and responses which I can then come back to later to help jog my memory. So if I jump over to Organizer
which is a new tool on the top level tab, we can see that it's currently empty. So let's add some
things to it. You can add requests and their responses to Organizer using the Send to Organizer
feature which you can find in the context menu or you can use the Send to Organizer hotkey which is
mapped to Command O on Mac and maybe Control O in Windows and Linux. So if I send a few requests over
with their responses, we can see that they've entered the Organizer table with the new status.
Now the Status column is a new feature in Virp that allows you to keep track of where this request is up
to in your testing workflow. So if you're not interested in it anymore. Furthermore, if you don't
want to see it anymore, you can delete using the context menu. Once you select one of the entries in
Organizer, you can see the request and response in the editors below and you can also see that we've
added a new notes free text editor here. So you can add any additional information that you want.
For example, hello. So that data will then be stored alongside your request and response in your project
file. So the next time you open Virp, all of that will be available to you even in six months time
when you've forgotten completely about where you found this and what it meant. Similar to other places
in Virp, we have filter and sorting functionality being a table and we also have a free text search
field which search the request, response and notes if you're looking for something specific.
Finally, if I jump back to Repeater, we've also added the new notes pane to the sidebar in the
Repeater tool. So as you're manually evaluating a website, you found something interesting. You can
add some notes to the request and response and send it over to Organizer. So if I jump here, I can see
that it's come from the Repeater tool and the notes have been passed across. It's important to note that
Organizer entries are snapshots of the original. They're not linked to the original. So any changes
made to the version in Repeater will not come across to Organizer. You'll need to send that across
and create a new entry. That's all for me for now. We're always working on Organizer. We are hoping to
add Montori API support in the very near future. So look out for that. And if you have any feedback,
we'd love to hear it. Thank you.